WOJTEK KALICINSKI: Android
Studio 3.0 is a major release,
and with it we're also releasing
version 3 of the Android Gradle
plugin.
It is based on new
Gradle APIs, supports
variant-aware
dependency resolution,
and can greatly speed
up multi-module builds.
Unfortunately, you might
have to make some updates
to your Gradle
configuration when switching
to the new plugin version.
It's just a few steps, and
it's well worth the effort.
You'll end up with a more
maintainable build file
and a faster build.
When you first open your
existing project in Android
Studio 3, you will be prompted
to update the Android plugin
version.
We also require, at
minimum, Gradle 4.1,
and this will be automatically
fixed for you too.
If you want to make
these changes manually,
you need to check two places.
First, in the main build
Gradle file, change AGP version
to 3.0.
Next, open the Gradle Wrapper
properties file and edit
the URL to point to 4.1.
By the way, as an
optional step, you
can add the new Google Maven
Repository to your main
build file.
We use it to distribute
our build artifacts,
such as the support library.
And with the latest
Gradle version,
you can simply refer to
it with a Google keyword.
If you try to compile your
app now with the new plugin,
and you are using
flavors in your modules,
you will most probably
get this error.
Previously, flavored
dimensions were optional.
In order to make resolving
flavors and library
modules more robust,
you are now required
to specify a dimension
for each flavor.
The Android Gradle
plugin will automatically
use a matching flavor
from consumed libraries
if it can find one.
If the library defines flavor
dimensions which are not
present in your
main build file, you
have to make an
explicit selection using
the new missing
dimension strategy
statement in the module
consuming the library listing
the flavors you like
to match in order.
And conversely, if a
library module does not
have a flavor that matches
one defined in your app,
you will have to
specify a fallback.
Use the matching fallbacks
keyword in the app's flavor
definition followed
by the possible flavor
names that will be selected
from library modules.
You can do the same
for build types
whenever the app includes
a build type that a library
dependency does not.
A nice side effect
of these changes
is that you no longer
have to specify
which variant you
want to consume when
depending on a library module.
You should remove
these extra lines
from the dependency section and
just include the library once.
You can also remove
publishNonDefault
true from library modules.
For external
dependencies, it's still
fine to use a variant
specifier if you only wanted
to be added to certain builds.
By the way, there's one more
detail here that changed.
Android plugin 3 is adopting
new dependency configurations
introduced in Gradle.
As you can see in
the table here,
this is just a name change
for most dependency types.
Compile becomes API, and
provided becomes compile only.
However, there is
one new configuration
called implementation, which
when applied correctly,
can result in significant
build time improvements.
You should prefer using the
implementation configuration
whenever a module only uses
the dependency internally
and doesn't intend to leak
its API to other modules.
That way whenever the
dependency changes,
you limit the number of
modules that would otherwise
have to be recompiled.
These are the basic
changes that every Android
project should make when
migrating to Android Gradle
plugin 3.
More migration scenarios are
covered in our documentation,
such as when handling
annotation processors
or using the variant API
to access build outputs.
So please take a look at
the link in the description.
And thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]